rebels in Bangkok celebrate the Thai new
year with water fights a tradition that
marks the beginning of the rainy season
but this year it brought record
temperatures
45.4 degrees Celsius a new high even for
a country accustomed to hot weather
outside the Grand Palace a temporary
respite from the heat for the birds and
lots of umbrellas but not a drop of rain
and sight I think it is a little bit
hotter this year it's very hot this time
of year anyway the rainy season will
come in a month or so but this period is
hotter than the rainy season
the heat wave is being filled all across
South and Southeast Asia Bangladesh's
capital Dhaka reached temperatures of 42
degrees Celsius hotter than it's been in
decades not so bad for those who can
afford to retreat indoors into the air
conditioning but potentially
life-threatening for those that can't
but while Millions across the region are
feeling the heat there's little
governments can do
knowing exactly where your vulnerable
population is and how to create measures
that reduce and mitigate the impact of a
heat wave on them is actually quite
difficult to do in rural India average
temperatures of five degrees higher than
usual for this time of year agricultural
workers have little Choice when it comes
to working under the glare of the Sun
and even if they can find somewhere to
shelter their land is baking
the temperatures have gone up
considerably in recent years earlier it
would never go above 37 degrees Celsius
now it goes up to 45 degrees the heat is
extremely harsh my body is dehydrated it
needs water and so do my crops the heat
is so bad that even if you irrigate them
they are still dry
with the Mercury Rising Everyone's
Watching The forecasts and hoping for
rain here in Bangkok the temperatures
have gone
decrees
and now is
soon rain start if they don't come soon
it's going to be a long hot summer Tony
Chang Al Jazeera Bangkok